and we're going to see Conor McGregor
back in a high profile fight
he is back in the gym he's training and
uh yeah I I expect to see Connor
fighting next year
does it matter that he's lost
a few big fights recently does that
impact on his ability to put bums on
seat sell tickets
well here's what happens Pearson I you
know this I'm sure you've seen this with
colleagues and friends and and people
that you know
um once a certain level of money
is attained
you know to to to be the person that you
were coming up to be that hungry and and
work that hard and be that dedicated to
the sport or or whatever craft it is you
do money changes everything and Conor
McGregor has made that kind of money